the biggest scam in human history is
you've already been scammed wake up look
at the world as it is not as how you
think it should be I remember there were
nights where I actually literally work
to exhaustion and I fell asleep on my
desk the only difference between me and
everybody else I can execute it better
than most people need motivation watch a
top 10 with belief nation what's that
belief nation at seven I believe in you
and this channel is designed to be part
of your daily success routine so let's
get your motivation to attend and get
you believing in you grab a snack and
chew in today's lessons from a man who
went from having his first job working
minimum wage at a grocery store at age
16 to starting and failing at multiple
businesses to eventually finding his
excess and becoming a multi-millionaire
by the age of 27 he's Dan Locke and
here's my take on his top ten roses
success volume 7 joy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one pay the price I remember the first
five years when I was building my empire
building my business that first five
years I was working I did not take a
single day off for five years strict I
was working every single day 12 to 14
hours I remember there were nights where
I actually literally worked to
exhaustion and I fell asleep on my desk
that's the price that I pay why all my
friends they were drinking partying
watching sports game and then chasing
girls I didn't do any of that I was
focused I was obsessed because I was
willing to pay for the price for success
I was committed to spend a few years
doing whatever it takes doing things
that other people are not willing to do
making sacrifices that other people are
not willing to make so that I could do
what I want to do for the rest of my
life what about you
how bad do you want it what's the price
you are willing to pay rule number two
wake up and one of the most common
things I see that haters critics are
posting is Dan lock is a scam
these are scam artists it's a fraud in
order for me to coin quote scam you I
will need something from you which I
don't please don't do me any favor don't
buy my books don't buy my course don't
don't even watch my video don't don't do
me any favors do me a favor don't watch
my stuff I don't need anything from you
I don't need a penny from you ever I
don't even want you to to buy anything
please let me know your name I'll put
you on the list so to make sure my team
knows I won't I know
please do not spend a penny with me I do
not want anything from you I have
everything I need
now if everything I want the reality is
this the biggest scam in human history
you've already been scammed if you're
over 25 years old if you're honest if
you have nothing in your bank account
you have no money you're not living your
dreams you got nothing to show for
you've already been scared you have
nothing zero you've been scammed you've
been scammed by the school system you've
been scammed by the society you've been
scammed by the government you've been
scammed by the corporation you have
nothing
you've already been scammed don't one
can take anything from you guess you got
nothing for them to take you've got to
think about it give it scale by your
preconceived ideas of how things should
work but not actually how it works
wake up look at the world as it is not
as how you think it should be whenever
people want to make a change they want
to change their lives they don't want to
follow the traditional path go to school
get good grades get a job
what is your 65 hopefully with living
luck you can retire anyone there who
deviates from that path they're crazy
they are stupid why are you doing that
it is risky any one anything any course
that teaches people how to do that it's
a scam
it has to be a scam so when I charge a
tiny little bit of money for what I
teach that's a scam when in the school
system that you spend 10 20 30 50
$100,000 or more to get a school
education and you spend 4 years you get
into student loan if that's you comment
below share your story and somehow after
you graduate maybe you get a degree
maybe you get two degrees then you
cannot even get a job you cannot even
survive you cannot pay your bills you're
still hundreds of thousand dollars and
dead that's perfectly normal
that's the way to go and still people
are telling you your parents are telling
you that's the way to go your friends
are telling you
yep just stay on the path are you stupid
can't you see it is not working rule
number three
execute most people they let the ego get
in the way of success it's very easy you
notice because I I know that I know that
I know that what you don't know
you do not know it how do you know when
you know something if you don't live it
you don't know it
so those three words are very very
dangerous and they destroy your
potential they destroy your success why
because the minute you say I know that
your brain shuts down you're not
listening anymore and you're like okay I
know that I don't I don't need to listen
any further you're not paying attention
so what you know it so what that you
know it it's not about knowing it I
could tell you this I am NOT an original
thinker let me just tell it to the whole
world I am NOT an original thinker
there's nothing new about what I do
everything I learned from Napoleon Hill
are the successful entrepreneurs Think
and Grow Rich proven masters from the
past my mentors there is absolutely
nothing new about what I say and about
what I do
I am a synthesizer I take different
ideas I put it together the only
difference between me and everybody else
is I don't say I know that what do I say
I say I use that I use that that's a
those three words are much more powerful
than I say I know that because when I
use it I own it it is mine I did instead
of everybody else
there's thinking the idea is that
learning about it I know that I know
that I know that no you want I ask how
can I use it how can I use that how can
I use that I implement the only
difference between me and everybody else
I can execute it better than most people
I use it better than most people that's
the only difference instead of you just
watching a video you watch 50 hundred
videos you don't use I can use one video
I can read one book I can take ideas and
like implement execute immediately and
execute well that's the only difference
rule number four find the right mentors
my marchand instructor said something to
be very profound a few years ago he said
you know what as a martial artist and
what determines how good you are and how
fast you will progress as a martial
artist it's not just how many hours you
put into your training and what
now that you practice what determines
how good you'll become is your Sifu your
instructor and who you'll learn from now
at first I didn't quite understand and
later after I study with him I trained
with him my March instructor I realized
wow what a profound statement because
think about in a martial art context
imagine if you want to learn different
martial art you want to learn Karma God
you will learn Taekwondo you'll learn
karate
you will learn boxing whatever style or
MMA whatever style that you decide to
choose your instructor would dictate
would determine how good you are
you'll coach their skill that gets
transferred to you
think about that it's the same in your
financial life who do you want to learn
from realize when you learn from
somebody when you listen to the advice
you become them you get their lifestyle
rule number five master don't dabble
master don't dabble master don't dabble
master don't gobble a lot of
entrepreneurs they have this what I call
Chinese optic syndrome okay it's oh it's
it's the social media it's his periscope
its Twitter its Facebook its whatever
flavor of the week of flavor of the
month they never take the time to master
anything focus on one thing and build on
the next master one in my career I focus
on building one skill first and then a
builder Nick's first I focus on
marketing that focus on internet
marketing then I focus on management
leadership then I focus on on deal
making investing but one thing a time so
my approach is more like this most
entrepreneurs approaches like this you
got to build build one thing be
successful and then work on it rule
number six don't make excuses the other
four words that are very very dangerous
they'll ruin your life is I can't afford
it I only said that to yourself how many
said that maybe just yesterday maybe
just today comment below I can't afford
it now this I learn from Kiyosaki again
nothing new he talks about when people
say I can't afford it again it's just on
your brain this there is no creativity
required when you say I can't afford it
you want something in your life I can't
afford it I want to buy that car I can't
afford it I want to point my my parent I
can't afford it
I want to take that vacation I can't
afford it I want to send my kids to
college I can't afford it you see how it
is I can't afford a quarter I can't
afford it it's an easy way out because
you're just making an excuse so I can't
afford it
it requires no effort that's a poor
person's mentality and you know that's
poor people say that I can't afford it
what you think money grows on trees I'm
gonna heard that before
comment below instead of saying I can't
afford it
ask yourself a powerful question and
that is how can I afford it how can I
afford it the minute you ask that it
opens up a world of possibility the
minute you change your vocabulary
instead of a statement a victim
statement I can't afford it huh stop how
can I afford it maybe I can't afford it
with my current job maybe I can't afford
it with the way that I'm conducting
business but how can I afford it what do
I need to do what what knowledge don't
need to acquire who do I have to be what
new skill sets I need to develop in
order for me to afford this do you see
how those questions are much more
powerful much more empowering wouldn't
you say so how can I afford it rule
number seven have clarity when people
come to me and say hey Dan I want to
make more money I would say here you go
he's a dime
you just made more money you see the
problem with an answer that is dead big
it doesn't give you power and doesn't
give you clarity so it's not just a bell
you know I want to make more money how
much more money exactly do you want to
make and also I always say it's not just
how much money you make is how you make
the money what would you do for money
what would you not do for money where do
you want to live do you like a big house
do you want to tag house do you want to
live in a condo or do you want to live
in a penthouse you know what kind of car
do you drive is not good enough to just
say oh I want to drive a Mercedes
exactly what color what model what
upgrades do you want
they'll give you a perfect example I've
had multiple opportunities come across
my table where it will require me to go
to Asia and do more business in Asia
Multi multi multi-million dollar
opportunity but in order to do that it
will require me to maybe stay here for
six months in Canada and then go to Asia
for six months a lot of travel back and
forth and ask myself hmmm the money is
good but that's it fit in my lifestyle
is this something that I want and I said
no that's not something I want I prefer
to stay home I don't want to travel as
much so there you go what I will and
what I won't do for money right where do
you want to travel how often what hotels
you want to stay here
what kind of charities do you want to
help who do you want to help what kind
of investments do you want to own you're
like real estate
do you like stocks you like bonds mutual
funds whatever it is that you want to
invest in that's clarity you cannot act
and you cannot take action you cannot
improve your financial situation if you
don't have clarity lack of clarity means
lack of power and power is the ability
to take action extreme clarity leads to
you extreme results rule number eight
walk your own path the biggest thing
that holds most people back it's not the
how-to it's not the know what it's not
don't know what to do it's not the
business idea is the fact that they
cannot operate on their own
being able to self motivate at the same
time not having to get permission from
the people around them that they wish
how come
don't you know I'm doing this for you
how come my how come you guys don't
support me how come my family don't
support me how come they don't
understand I don't get it I want to make
more money I want to be more successful
to better their lives how come they
don't understand guess what most of time
they will never understand you're
expecting something that that won't
happen that's what's holding you back
you're expecting them to give you
permission yeah go for the cheer you up
no now the question is why don't they
support you
it's very simple it's very very simple I
go through this whole thing exactly in
my own life
first of all they don't understand
because most of us we grew up in the
Miss educational system where it's
teaching you to behave a certain way go
to school get good grades and walk this
path get a degree get a job work to is
65 marry have kids get a get a big
mortgage that's your life anything that
deviates from that anything that's not
the traditional path that is stupid
that is dangerous that is wrong you
shouldn't do that you should do this so
the minute you want to walk a different
path you're the people around you your
loved ones they feel like you're so
weird how come you can't do what
everybody else just just be normal just
saddle just just why we don't take risk
play safe
you can say secure job and the more you
deviate from that traditional path the
more they feel like they're the bigger
the distance between you and them they
are afraid to lose you they're afraid
that to lose you T the afraid that you
leave them behind that's why you don't
have to support and all your buddies are
your friends do you really think they
want you to be mega successful to to
lift that dream life to travel live in
that beautiful home to drive that car
that they can never afford do you really
think they want to be that successful
while they are living paycheck to
paycheck health no they might say oh
yeah we cheer for you we could
congratulations man good for you deep
down in venous jealousy lower self is
human nature so what I'm saying is don't
don't even expect it you're wasting your
time you do what you think is right you
do what you believe it's right you walk
your own path
they might see it they might not see I'm
not expecting to see you this is my life
it's not their life I do what I know I
need to do rule number nine learn how to
deal with rejection is that five minutes
into the conversation you made multiple
four
medical errors and you speak with an
accent I don't think I trust you to
write my copy and he said I think your
photos and he hung up now at a time I
was already feeling very insecure about
English as my second language there's
the first time in my life that I felt
rejected I felt embarrassed humiliated
and I was so mad and so pissed off first
at the prospect
how dare he talks to me like that why
does he have to attack me like that what
did I do
all I'm trying to do is to make a living
and provide for my mom why does he call
me names why does he personally attack
me like that and then I made a decision
the decision that would forever change
my life I said to myself you know what
from now on I don't want to feel that
again I'm gonna work on my English I'm
gonna work on myself so that someday one
day not only that are we able to speak
with clarity and conviction and
confidence someday as a Chinese as an
Asian as an immigrant someday I would
have these guys pay to hear me talk they
were paid to hear me speak hear what I
have to say and I did that see how many
times your life sometimes you feel
rejected now if you people just why do
people with Jack you like this for no
good reason whatsoever maybe is a job
interview maybe it's a business deal
maybe it's a relationship your loved one
your girlfriend your boyfriend that they
break up with you when you feel so
rejected one thing I've learned about
rejection is it all depends on
perspective sometimes the same business
in sales in closing you have to deal
with a lot of rejections in order to be
successful you have to talk to a lot of
strangers a lot of people saying no to
you if you want to make any significant
um
money but you see if you look at it that
way you will feel defeated you feel
rejected
but if during any closing call for
example if you look at that there are
three things you will get out of it
number one you will get it yes which
means you get a cell that's good number
two you could get an O which is
perfectly fine
it simply means you don't have to waste
more time with this prospect on number
three for sales that you don't close you
would get a lesson you'll learn from it
your growth of it I want to think back
all those moments in your life what you
fell we checked it I want you to think
back doesn't that shape who you are
today if you think about it those
moments those incidents those times
where you feel so bad but on those also
some of the greatest times without that
incident I wouldn't be where I am today
there will be no down lock and rule
number ten the last one before a very
special bonus clip is maximize high
income skills so what do you do if you
don't want to be an entrepreneur let me
tell you about my friend one now I'm
known run for almost ten years now he is
one of the highest paid photographer in
my city it takes a lot of different
photos one of the most expensive in my
city now he doesn't have a business he's
simply a photographer what ron has is a
high income skill if you follow my work
you know I believe in the power of
having the high income skill and I
define high income skills the skill that
can make you a minimum ten thousand
dollars a month Thank You month one
hundred twenty thousand dollars year or
more so ron has a high income skill
which is a high-end photographer now
he's a very frugal guy remember back
then he could have bought a a place a
house in Burnaby he's making very good
money but he bought a very modest home
not for a lot of money and him and its
wife and two kids living
and he keeps making more and more money
he put aside and saved those money and
put into real estate
he started off my smaller property
fixing them flipping them selling them
eventually moving into duplex bigger
bigger units and today after all these
years he owns over 200 units in
Vancouver now if you know Vancouver real
estate it is one of the most expensive
in the world
so he owns apartment buildings he owns
commercial properties 200 doors
200 units he doesn't have a business he
is not a business owner all over the
years he all he has is he has developed
botanical skills he has maximized his
high income skill and he takes that
money and put it into high return
investments in this case real estate
that's it
he's now worth tens of millions of
dollars
it's basically retired traveling with
the wife and traveling to all kinds of
countries enjoying life because every
month it's got rental income coming in
right so I want you to think about you
don't need to be an entrepreneur to be
successful financially what you need to
absolutely that you need it's high
income skills
now I've got a special bonus clip from
Dan on how to learn management skills
that I think you're gonna enjoy but
before that it's time for the
three-point landing question sign the
move from just watching another video to
taking action in your life or business
and if you're feeling bold leave your
answers in the comments below here we go
question number one what high income
skills will you commit to developing
number two what will you tell yourself
when you get rejected and number three
what excuse do you need to stop letting
yourself believe
company's only go out of business
because of miss management period
because maybe entrepreneurs the CEO they
miss manage the revenue they mismanaged
the cash flow they miss manage their
marketing they miss manage the employees
management now it's not something that's
easily taught management has to be
learned as was also leadership has to be
earned
so management is very very key how you
manage your team how you manage your
self self management hi this is Dan lock
if you're a fan of Evans work if you
want to know exactly how the model my
success I want to invite you to join me
for a special online training all you
have to do is click on a link below you
can join me for absolutely no charge so
click on link below
and I will see you in class
if you want more dan lock check at the
top 50 rules video that I made on him
the link is right there next to me I
think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there if your
life stinks it's your fault
we take responsibility for all action
our money is not the important money
doesn't buy happiness